16 games on the schedule tonight including this
one right here Gordon stall took the draw there
for Carolina they start with a puck that Dimitri
orof so the lightning shouldn't be used to playing
against that kind of team Carolina's been giving
up a ton of goals but they've also been scoring
watch here's a chance in tight coach J is down
and takes one away from point Puck stays alive
at the last set and to take away the Martin of
chance and in Carolina very uncharacteristically
nobody's within 20 ft of braen point Who's got
time and room and makes a move coach etco right
with him boy that's some nice go tending there
as he shuffled across back to Chad Hill brings
it around the boards again for the Kane picked
up by Tony D'Angelo across to Chatfield gets
it a sit down his shot gets through and there's
another save by Johansson chadfield D'Angelo shot
blocked and it is cleared by the lightning Cherry
up ahead to aot his shot and a glove save made by
coach jov who is completely snake bitten 51 goal
scor hasn't scored a goal yet hey Bra neither is
Alexandro Vin Cent pass there's Hegel with a shot
and ketov again makes a save that one on Brandon
Hegel man inside their own Zone well they are not
Manning up we showed you the Bron Point chance off
the face off where at all five guys go then they
all come back to words than that don't sh don't
sort it out Jarvis still trying to battle for
that pck senters it back to the line there's a
slap pass and a tip rebound and Johansson closes
the door at the near side post on kind of a broken
play but Carolina got a chance there and then
they had a tip play coming out of the corner
really dangerous plays for the golender in gu
who Sebastian AO 36 goal scorer last year for
Carolina and that's a really good save watch him
react back to this there and get the five hole
Clos I've really been impressed how good he
is with his legs it did get through net front
presence that's what you want Victor Hedman is
just pounding Puck at the net right from the and
they're taking a lot of penalties which is also
uncharacteristic Toyota power play first of the
game lightning set it up they scored two Power
Play Goals both by CRA on Saturday headman with
a shot [__] out the save in the rebound clear
had to make a long pass there over to Stan Co it
was a really good uh read by Chatfield to break up
the play but there's the shot that did get through
net front presence that's what you want Victor
Hedman is just pounding pucks at the net back to
the point for sergachev sergachev gives it up into
the middle of for cell back to sergachev sergachev
hangs on dying second to the man Advantage there's
a shot loose Puck swept at by Jano and ketov Puck
was bouncing a little Loose Change in front
he was behind everybody but when he goes to
sweep it with the back hand right here comes off
the slavens clears it but not out kept in shovel
back in off the Stick of AO and now it's back down
the ice and here's Jano Tanner Jano drops it back
trailers Mar with a shot coach jov got a piece to
the rebound and it goes into the corner here's din
again merilla Drive wide have guys going to the
net a little stop up and merilla coming late on
the play there's Celli driving through to the net
mer got a good shot away gives a little tap on
the Jano sees him coming good shot merilla knows
where to go and when to get there Power Play Goals
against most in the league and it's starting on
the face off they're losing too many of them they
lose again and the liting have it one minute to
go in behind the net that's Paul COV quick shot
tip scores and he's on the board Bren points power
play goal one nothing lightning I was joking with
Braden point when he arrived in the building
this evening said Braden it'll be tonight he
just Shrugged and smiled goes I know I know it's
it's coming said it'll probably go in off my leg
or something well it didn't that was a really
nice deflection that's the second really good
chance he's had being all alone in front of the
net he's always that guy it's going to be Celli
against stall Jordan Stall 35 years of age just
got rewarded with a 4-year contract extension in
Carolina in the off season centering pass does not
connect with Celli onto the back end that was ahle
and it's Chip back in by the lightning Jano out
in front Rolling Puck save by coach jov but prior
to that lightning get the puck in the offensive
zone good push Jano turns the puck over gets it
out out in front and it was Celli Celli got that
chance I thought merilla had gotten there first
but Celli got a good look at it and look where the
goal tender ends up he had a big strong puts the
fckin over the side four as the St Coast was up
on the four check and now here's a bang pass up
ahead for f his shot saved by Johanson rebound
and he got that to as Martin n following up on
the opposite side for bench here line changes
better be good and better be efficient and here's
a a chance for for fast really good save there
by and Banks back out through [Music] center
chadfield with the lane going to go for a skate
wi fakes shoots and a tricky shot does not fool
Johansson he's got it quickly Outlets that and
Nikita drop through center right puts it Wide
Point back across bar ble in back across
up top rtis shoots tip scores Alex bar
[Applause]
Boule on the initial Rush watch braon
point with a crossy pass Bari Boule
runs out of racetrack really good
goal tending there by kuskov and
then look at radish he sees Bari Boule
coming out from behind the net all the
Carolina Hurricanes are facing up the
ice nobody looks around for number 12
when this team is at its best they close these
games out and this has been something that has
been drilled home to them the last 48 hours and
here we go third period yeah there there's a lot
of movement there's a lot of time in between
whistles for sure so there that kind of flow
but turnover is turnover the tight checking AO out
of the corner blocker save by Johanson and here's
CRA Point cra going wide on orloff he's in kov
WRA around ketov makes the save on the rebound
is cleared by Carolina COV drops it off into
back line for headman he's pressured by stall
Jordan Stall into the middle for martinook
martinook takes it wide got a shot away and
Johansson makees that up now they're going to
flip it right back in with three minutes to
go KN as Side by orlock Brandon Hegel Hegel
hangs on to the puck gets it away they score
a great feed by Hegel buried by Paul now watch
Hegel here real nice job watch Paul will sift
his way back out away from everybody look at
the release and the goal tender is in tight
but there's room on the far side beautiful shot
terrific execution all the way along there it is
Paul goes okay I'll just sip my way in between
behind everybody and that is Catch and Release
as good as you can get and then after that is
when the commotion started yeah that was right
in the crook of the arm right in the elbow the
player comes out of the box that was Mason lots
of pressure here for Carolina final minute of
Regulation quick shot saved by Johanson and
he's got the rebound reaction was great look
how tight he is to the net there and there's
chernack tries to stop the initial pass but
then does the right thing and goes to Jarvis
coming to his feet here's kinami takes the shot
tip one more save by Johansson and you can make
it a shut out the second of his NHL career
and what a story he's becoming in Tampa Bay